hi i'm lily collins and i play emily
cooper i'm ashley clark and i play mindy
chen hi i'm lucy laviscown and i play
alfie i'm camille and i play a camille
hi i'm lucas bravo and i play gabrielle
and we are here with buzzfeed to play a
little quiz to figure out which
characters emily and paris we really are
[Music]
okay so first things first how likely
are you to drop everything and move to a
new country for a year not at all
i would have to think about it maybe
only with a friend sure i already bought
my ticket i
i feel like you would change it to only
with the husband enough
this is i'd have to talk to my husband
first but honestly i'd say like sure i
feel like i'm definitely and i already
bought my ticket oh i would concur
i said maybe because i'm not sure
are you okay
i bought my ticket out i'm sat next to
ashley on the plane
we out of that girl we out of there yeah
i'm i'm already there i bought my ticket
like a month ago i'm waiting for you
guys yeah i mean all the same so
maybe it's a yes now if you're all there
i think your maybe should turn into a
shore and then we're the same and we'll
just meet them there later yeah or now
yours is only with a friend because now
that your friends are all gone yeah
you're gonna go but it's just great
sure yeah sure yeah sure great pick a
film to watch at le champo amelie moulin
rouge les miserables hugo that in
touchables and ratatouille lily if you
don't beat me i don't know what to say
did you say amelie
oh no i don't want like it was the bbc
right now lily calls this font i do that
i think mine is moulin rouge oh yeah
moon and rose every day every hour every
day every night every i love the country
yes i'm gonna say amelie because i just
love audrey tattoo
i picked emily because also of the music
of yanchez and that i love very much so
why don't we actually watch that on the
plane on the way over to whatever
country they're on because we're
traveling together it's great
i'm i'm being in touchables i i thought
that film really happened
it's a great movie i haven't watched
domilia you have to watch it what is
your love language physical touch acts
of service quality time words of
affirmation gifts
does gina say quoi love language what
does that mean i've never heard of
jonathan as a love language what does
that mean french luca our community what
does that mean it's a it's a mix of
everything and even jonah sequoia in
french is like this jonathan was this
charm that you got but you don't know
about
physical touch i'm gonna go with words
of affirmation okay
i'm so interested to know what your love
language is
act of service
i would have said quality time for you
but
i hesitated that was between the two is
it the love language that you give or
that it's what you want oh yeah no it's
what you give oh
no
no
it's what is it what's your love
language what would make you feel most
loved
yeah say luca yeah i would say it's in
between physical touch and and acts of
service because physical touch gets old
at some points i guess act of service so
it's just wow
you mean i'm the only one that needs to
be told how amazing i am no that's just
your
one you and your paranoia are going on a
romantic getaway where are you all
headed
san jose
florence santorini prague amsterdam uber
i love berlin i take berlin yeah i know
you love berlin i still haven't been to
amsterdam which i really want to go to
but for a romantic getaway i think
greece i think santorini i'm gonna i
feel like charlie would probably
wanna go to uh i'm gonna go yeah
amsterdam i'm gonna go to amsterdam
because we haven't done that yet
nothing's beautiful where you go for uh
florence undisputed florence i i went to
a wedding there and it was the most
magical place i've ever been to how
about you lucian what did you say i need
some sunshine my people yeah yeah
santorini uh which iconic french
landmark are you posing in front of for
a selfie
the felt blue versailles
notre dame
i feel like we've done zombies in front
of all of these
everything else just quite obvious it's
like same well i'm a basic [ __ ] so
i'm with you girl i'm with you girl
i'm going to go with probably like
eiffel tower because it just never gets
old i am really a baseball because i
want selfies in front of all of them
maybe for psy actually i was going to
say versailles yeah i was like that
would be it's like there's so like so
many mirrors that i'd like definitely
catch the back of myself but the garden
is so pretty too and the fountain's
pretty there's true what did you guys
say again i went for versailles yes kami
what about you
example like lucas which hashtag best
describes your life hashtag let them eat
cake
it's all french to me hashtag celebi
work work hard play harder
everything's coming up roses or hashtag
rengard
[ __ ]
work hard to play harder is my motto it
really is crazy say lovey because i feel
like everything happens for a reason so
it's just like okay well
just go on with life although i really
do love rain guard [ __ ] but
lucious um you know what i'm going to go
for i'm going to go for um i feel like i
work so so hard
i'm going to play even harmony
uh work hard play harder
or
rain guard [ __ ] i will yeah i picked
that yeah
i would say let them eat cake because
because i love cooking and baking and
and also it's the most iconic uh line in
the in season two i don't think that's
what it means
last but not least pick a hat y'all pick
a chapeau the navy blue golf hat with
the red pom pom look at lilly's little
face the pastel pink dior cap the red
beret the checkered bucket hat the hot
pink bucket hat striped butter hat what
is it
oh he got his character no wait wait
we don't know what did you say for the
hat don't look
just say what you got for the hat
a little bit of cool jace i want for the
kangal hat
the kangal hat the problem is lily looks
good in all of these hats the only hat
that i can pull off is a beret so i'd go
with the red beret i'm gonna go with the
striped boater hats i feel like it's
like
chic and different and i'm also wearing
stripes so that's what i'm gonna do
what'd you guys do i did the red
barrettes but by mistake but yeah
look at what you do i got the red beret
because i love this outfit with the you
know the black and white uh suit that
you're wearing in season one i think
this this is one of my favorite ones
[Music]
i got me
thank god emily
um well i think it probably says the
same thing it says you got emily you're
determined hard-working and a tray loyal
friend sometimes you tend to put other
people's needs above your own but you
deserve everything that you give to
others plus tax i agree
yeah
emily cooper out here too what did you
guys get i got emily cooper as well but
gabrielle no way
you're a mystery wrapped up in a chef's
coat but the package is
chef's kiss you love fearlessly and
deeply which can sometimes hurt the ones
around you but it's only because your
passion can obtain or tempered wait are
you serious or did you just make that up
so hold it up so we can see fine we all
got emily but luca
that is really funny thank you buzzfeed
that is all for us please make sure that
you watch emily in paris on netflix
[Music]